?
WILL YOU SAY SOMETHING ABOUT IT?
SHE DID NOT RESPOND.
THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE HAS JUS
HIRED A FORMER PRODUCER OF GOOD
MORNING AMERICA CALLED JAMES
GOLDSTON.
HE WILL OVERSEE THE PRIMETIME
HEARINGS ON THURSDAY NIGHT.
THE SHOW TRIAL NOW HAS A
PRODUCTION CREW.
THEY WILL BE COVERING THAT IN
GREAT DETAIL ON THURSDAY.
BY ARRESTING PETER NAVARRO THEY
HOPE TO SHUT UP THE LOCAL
CRITICS BEFORE IT BEGINS.
PETER NAVARRO IS A BRAVE MAN WH
IS NOT SHUTTING UP.
HE JOINS US NOW FOR HIS FIRST
INTERVIEW SINCE BEING ARRESTED.
HE IS A FORMER SENIOR WHITE
HOUSE ADVISOR AND THE AUTHOR OF
TAKING BACK TRUMP'S AMERICA.
HE JOINS US NOW.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
HOW IS THIS ALLOWED?
THIS IS SO OUTSIDE THE BOUNDS.
UNLESS I AM MISSING SOMETHING,
AND IF I AM YOU WILL CORRECT IT.
THIS IS NOT HOW A CIVILIZED
COUNTRY BEHAVES.
DID YOU SEE IT COMING?
IF NOT, HOW WAS IT ALLOWED TO
HAPPEN?
>> CERTAINLY, I SAW IT COMING.
WE HAVE ENTERED REALLY DANGEROU
UNPRECEDENTED WATERS.
TUCKER, I WAS IN A POSITION
WHERE A PARTISAN COMMITTEE HAS
WEAPONIZE THE INVESTIGATORY
POWERS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
PREVENTING DONALD TRUMP FROM
EVER GETTING BACK IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THEY SUBPOENAED ME ILLEGALLY.
I WAS FACED WITH THE UNTENABLE
CHOICE OF UPHOLDING EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, WHICH WAS NOT MY PLA
VILLAGE TO WAIVE.
THAT IS DONALD TRUMP'S TO
PRIVILEGE TO WAIVE.
I DID MY DUTY TO THE PRESIDENT.
I DID MY DUTY TO THIS COUNTRY
AND HERE WE SIT.
THE CIVIL SUIT I FILED, TUCKER,
I HOPE WILL BE HISTORICALLY
IMPORTANT.
THERE'S REALLY TWO
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES AT STAKE.
THE FIRST WITH THE WEAPONIZATIO
THAT CONGRESS HAS INVESTIGATORY
POWERS IS A CLEAR VIOLATION OF
THE SEPARATION OF POWERS IN OUR
CONSTITUTION.
THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH IS NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE THE JUDGE, JURY
AND EXECUTIONER.
I HEARD ONE OF YOUR COMMENTATOR
WHEN YOU PLAYED THE CLIP.
THE PURPOSE WAS TO PUNISH PETER
NAVARRO.
THAT IS NOT THEIR ROLE.
THAT'S THE JUDICIARY ROLE.
THAT ALONE IS SUFFICIENT TO
RENDER WHAT THEY HAVE DONE
ILLEGAL AND THEREFORE WHAT WHAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE DID
ILLEGAL.
THE BIGGER ISSUE, TUCKER, AND
THIS IS WHERE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND COMMITTEE WAS SO
DISINGENUOUS.
I ASSERT EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
PREVENTING ME FROM COMPLYING
WITH THE SUBPOENA.
INSTEAD OF GOING TO TALK AND
NEGOTIATE THE PRIVILEGE WITH
DONALD TRUMP AS THE LAW REQUIRES
, THEY WENT INTO THIS
ABSURD NOTION THAT BIDEN, A
SITTING INCUMBENT PRESIDENT
COULD STRIP HIS IMMEDIATE
PREDECESSOR OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, AND ME, A STAFF
MEMBER TO THE PRESIDENT, OF WHA
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ITSELF,
AS YOU POINTED OUT, HAS
ABSOLUTELY TESTIMONY IMMUNITY.
IT IS ABSURD ON ITS FACE.
EVERY STEP ALONG THE LINE-
>> I HAVE NO DOUBT IT'S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
I JUST WANT TO GET TO THE CENTE
OF IT WHICH IS JANUARY 6.
THIS IS THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE.
YOU SAW LIZ CHENEY IN THAT
DISGUSTING, RIDICULOUS INTERVIEW
.
DID YOU HAVE ANYTHING AT ALL TO
DO WITH JANUARY 6TH?
>> NO.
YOU HAD THAT EXACTLY RIGHT.
WHAT YOU AND I HAVE NOW BOTH
SAID, WHICH IS ABSOLUTE FACT, I
THE MISSION OF THAT PARTISAN
WITCHHUNT KANGAROO COMMITTEE,
WHICH IS UNDULY AUTHORIZED AND
NOT PROPERLY CONSTITUTED AND HA
NO SUBPOENA POWER.
THEY HAVE ONLY ONE MISSION, TO
CONCOCT A FAKE HOAX AROUND
JANUARY 6TH BASED ON CRIMINAL
CHARGES AGAINST TRUMP TO PREVEN
HIM FROM RUNNING FOR REELECTION
AND TAKING BACK THE WHITE HOUSE
AND 2025 JANUARY.
THAT IS ALL THIS IS ABOUT.
LOOK, TUCKER, YOU SAID IT.
I LIVE RIGHT NEXT DOOR, 50 YARD
FROM THE FBI.
ON WEDNESDAY NIGHT I SENT AN
E-MAIL TO PATRICIA, THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY AND SAID I AM SEEKING
MODE IS HERE.
I'M STUCK BETWEEN A ROCK AND A
HARD PLACE.
I GAVE HER THE NAME OF AN
ATTORNEY AND TOLD WALTER, THE
FBI AGENT WHO CAME BANGING ON M
DOOR AT THE WEEK BEFORE.
I AM HERE, JUST CALL ME.
NO NEED TO BANG ON MY DOOR.
THEY CHOSE A DIFFERENT ROUTE.
THEY DIDN'T CALL MY ATTORNEY.
INSTEAD THEY WENT THROUGH THE
SHOCK AND AWE, AND LET ME GO TO
THE AIRPORT AND THEN TAKE ME
WITH FIVE AGENTS LIKE I AM AN A
QAEDA TERRORIST.
THEY LOCK BEING IN A CAR AND TH
NEXT THING I KNOW I AM IN LEG
IRONS, HANDCUFFS AND
STRIP-SEARCHED.
IT WAS NOT WITHOUT COMITY.
AT ONE POINT THE FBI AGENTS
COULD NOT FIND THE DOOR TO GO
INTO.
THE FINGERPRINT MACHINE DIDN'T
WORK.
PEOPLE DO NOT WANT TO SIT IN
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT IN LEG
IRONS DENIED FOOD, DENIED WATER
DENIED AN ATTORNEY.
THIS IS WHAT WE LIVE IN.
I STUDIED IN COLLEGE AND IT TOO
ME UNTIL I WAS 72 TO UNDERSTAND.
>> YOU CANNOT ARREST PEOPLE FOR
POLITICAL REASONS.
IT IS VERY SIMPLE.
WE'VE INVITED EVERY MEMBER OF
THAT COMMITTEE ON THIS SHOW.
THEY ARE ALL COWARDS.
I THINK THIS IS A HUGE CHANGE I
THE WAY THIS COUNTRY OPERATES
AND I WANTED TO EXTEND OUR
SYMPAT